my PMS slash birthday Edition but I mean  bikes are healthy today because if I  know I'm getting my period soon I really  make sure I'm healthy to avoid any  period cramps we just want to be  cautious about putting too much stock  into eating very healthy or in her case  actually identifying as a very healthy  person which can be a bit of a slippery  slope into disordered eating behaviors  like orthorexia second can you eat your  way out of period cramps we know that  Ultra processed foods are typically  higher in salt and saturated fats the  former of which can increase feelings of  water attention while the ladder can  increase prostaglandin production which  may increase the severity of cramps if  you also find yourself constipated  thanks to the extra progesterone leading  up to ant flow boosting your fiber and  water intake can also help to move  things along if this helps you get  through shark week then by all means